Ми живемо в Україні
де триває війна де летять ракети і ми не
можемо про це не говорити тому що це
наше щоденне життя
відбувалося на кузові вантажівки це була
така маленька сцена але ми змогли
обмінятися хорошими емоціями з
відважними українськими воїнами
Ми хочемо подарувати живі емоції під час
нашого виступу і вразити глядачів
Ми сподіваємося що наш перфоманс надихне
людей по всій планеті
буде трохи сильнішими і в поганих
ситуаціях не падати духом а боротися йти
вперед з посмішкою
Сьогодні ми говоримо з представниками
української електронної музики і
представниками України на цьогорічному
Євробаченні гуртом творчій Андрію чи
авто Вітаю вас Дякую що погодилися на цю
розмову
ми домовлялися про цю зустріч майже
місяць і до останнього не знали чи вона
відбудеться Я так розумію що у вас в
житті зараз дуже насичений період
Розкажіть будь ласка як живете
напередодні Євробачення зараз це дуже
важкий час і ми в нас є дуже багато
роботи і ми дуже багато
репети- репетирували і ми так відвідуємо
промоподію які забезпечені Євробачення
були нещодавно в Барселоні в тель-авіві
і ближчим часом відвідаємо Амстердам там
де є багато інтерв'ю розказуємо про
Україну і
виступаємо і далі нас почалися репетиції
нещодавно були декілька таких прямо
зранку до вечора Так але ми в захваті
працюємо для того щоб представити нашу
Україну найкращим чином незважаючи
Я продовжую свій біль світ палає а ти
дід 9 березня ви презентували оновлену
версію конкурсної пісні Ми в ній почули
і українську мову і оновлену кінцівку
Розкажіть будь ласка чому саме такі
зміни відбулися Нам потрібно було додати
пісню щось українське тому що ми
український гурт і представляємо Україну
ці слова дуже сильні і вони об'єднують
пісню Ось що я можу сказати
і додають нових сенсів тому що там є
рядки такі як світ палає а тоді і
означає що не важливо якби яка погана
ситуація ти повинен щось робити і
рухатись вперед Все буде добре
а в скрипки в кінці доповнюють пісню
додають драматичності всі композиції І
ідеально передають момент
тривожного моменту боротьби Коли ти
падаєш але встаєш ідеш вперед
[музика]
скільки часу пішло на роботу на
доновленою версією одразу після того як
ми в перемогли в національному відборі
ми працювали дуже багато використали
весь час по максимуму Там було дуже
багато різних версій але зупинились саме
на цій
за правилами конкурсу ви як представники
країни яка перемогла Минулого року
одразу потрапляєте у фінал Тобто ви
будете виступати у прямому ефірі лише
один раз і ваш виступ триватиме ну менше
трьох хвилин Скажіть будь ласка чим
вражатимете за цей час глядача Ми не
можемо сказати багато про наш номер тому
що ми хочемо подарувати живі емоції під
час нашого виступу і вразити глядачів
скажу одне що ми робимо все для того щоб
представити нашу Україну на найвищому
рівні і сподіваємося вам сподобається те
що ми готуємо
А яка загальне враження ви хочете
справити наглядача Ну от якщо брати
комплексно пісня постановка подача ваша
ми сподіваємося що наш перфоманс надихне
людей по всій планеті
буде трохи сильнішими і в поганих
ситуаціях не падати духом а боротися йти
вперед з посмішкою і якщо так станеться
комусь ця пісня сподобається вони
дотримують чутливі серця ми будемо дуже
раді на євробаче
нні до триває війна очевидно У вас
будуть запитувати про війну ви будете
розповідати про неї Розкажіть будь ласка
що хочете донести світові про Україну
перш за все ми хочемо подякувати всім
хто підтримує Україну в цій складні часи
тому що це дуже багато для нас значить і
ми будемо дуже раді і ваші підтримці аж
до нашої Перемоги
Також
ми живемо в цій країні тому ми будемо
розказувати те що відбувається в нашому
повсякденному житті і знаєте якщо б ми
жили десь на островах Ми мабуть
розказували Що відбувається на островах
А так ми живемо в Україні
де триває війна де летять ракети і ми не
можемо про це не говорити тому що це
наші щоденне життя ми ж можемо придумати
якусь іншу історію
А як під час війни пишеться музика із
інших
це цікаво тому що відчуття різні теми
різні Але в нашій ситуації у нас були є
досі повітряні тривоги я можу сказати що
вони відволікають тому що ви не можете
повністю розслабитися тому що ви не
знаєте що може статися далі Це дуже
незручно Відчуття і це багато в чому
також стосується пісень як і впливає на
запис пісень був тривалий період коли не
було світла і нам потрібно було знайти
інше джерело електроенергії щоб записати
пісні але головне Перемога в кінці
Наскільки я знаю ви виступали перед
військовими Розкажіть будь ласка чим
запам'яталися ці виступи для вас
Отже коли ми виступали у військовому
таборі я гадаю Це відбувалося на кузові
вантажівки це була така маленька сцена
але ми змогли обмінятися хорошими
емоціями з відважними українськими
воїнами крім того я дав одному з
військових свою панамку а він натомість
дав мені свій військовий кашкет Отже це
було дуже чудово як я це називаю сувенір
Я збираюся зберегти його але це справді
було надзвичайно мені сподобалось нам
було дуже приємно поспілкуватися з
українськими військовими поділитися з
ними можна сказати позитивними емоціями
Чому ви залиши в Україні після нападу
Росії
по-перше я можу сказати це мій другий
дім тому що я тут вже думаю близько 10
років Це було безперечно правильно я
почав займатися музикою ще до того як я
закінчив університет я вирішив
залишитися тому що я знайшов Тут те що
мені подобається робити а також зустрів
тут членів своєї команди своїх друзів і
я можу сказати що у мене тут є частина
своєї родини тож по суті Моє нове життя
тут тож це мій другий дім і я
насолоджуюся тим що я тут тим що я
створюю музику для людей які цінують те
що ми робимо Отже я насправді не маю
прямої відповіді на це питання можу
просто сказати що це мій другий дім тож
куди б я ще пішов
чи плану єте коли-небу
дь дуже хотів відвідати нігерію але ми
завжди зайняті Моя мама хоче щоб я
приїхав і залишився приблизно на три
тижні але так і обов'язково знайду час
для цього я не впевнений коли саме але
точно знайду час Так я цього дуже хочу
так ми також говоримо Джефрі коли ти
збираєшся привести всіх нас до Нігерії
будемо раді побачити та спробувати
місцеву їжу та все інше
І наостанок трохи про майбутнє який
максимум ви хочете отримати від
Євробачення Можливо в професійному плані
І взагалі яким бачите своє творче життя
після Євробачення для нас буде добре те
що ми представимо нашу Україну найкращім
чином і будемо задоволені зробленою
роботою а звісно про майбутні плани Ми
плануємо реліз нового альбому після
Євробачення відповідно і концерти
можливо якісь тури будемо випускати
музичні відео також тому попереду багато
роботи і ми вже хочемо поділитися
результатами
Дякую вам за цю розмову Бажаю успіху на
Євробаченні дякую